Hey, can I ask you, Umaro, why
did that friend leave the
village?
He said, "Don't do anything, it's for the sake of gaining power."
His clan and
our clan have been destroyed.
In order to cut ties,
loneliness and pain made
me stronger
That's why I said
that cutting ties with people
would make me stronger
, and I tried with all my might to stop
him 4 alleys
Why did you go all the way to help me and want to bring him back
?  I don't know how it feels, but I
'm in the same group as Sasuke I wondered if brothers were like this In
order to bring back the help
I have to be strong So I'll have the
erotic hermit train me
one more time to my heart's content  Let's beat him up and give him his name, but I'll bring him back to the
village, because he's my
friend.
I smoked it